[Music]
well you may be happy with the state of
the US economy but many young people are
not and as a result of that a lot of
them are embracing political extremism a
poll released today by YouGov finds that
half of all Millennials and even more of
the generation that follows them
distrust capitalism fully 70 percent of
Millennials say they would be willing to
vote for a socialist if you're not
shocked by this it's only because you
have seen it before polls like this
appear to be everywhere all of a sudden
and that ought to scare you it's taken
us almost 250 years to build this
country we could wreck it in a single
generation and at this rate we will
polls like this predict a looming
disaster
in order to prevent that we need to be
clear about what has gone wrong you
often hear it said that young people
support socialism because they've been
brainwashed by their professors and of
course there is truth in that if you've
got kids in college you know that we
have left the most vital job in America
educating the next generation of
citizens to some of the most mediocre
people in our society that's a huge
problem we need to fix it but believe it
or not it's not the main problem
the main problem the reason that
capitalism increasingly is discredited
and socialism increasingly is popular is
that our current system is making young
people poorer go to college we tell them
you'll be successful if you do but too
often that advice is outdated if not an
utter lie huge numbers of our kids wind
up impoverished by the experience of
college their dreams torta de reason for
that is debt forty-five million
Americans now labor under student loans
the average debt burden is 37 thousand
dollars per person that's the price of a
brand-new car imagine starting your
first job with that hanging over you and
keep in mind that college debt isn't
like ordinary debt thanks to a well
funding lobbying campaign student loans
cannot be erased by bankruptcy they last
forever many of today's college freshmen
can expect to spend their working lives
paying interest on loans that in the end
didn't help them at all
so no yet wonder young people aren't
getting married or buying homes or
having children they can't afford to
and no wonder so many of them support
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren if
this is capitalism they don't want any
part of it the irony of course is that
the only people benefiting from this
current system or on the far left the
smirking college presidents with
multi-million dollar salaries the
authoritarian university administrators
in the suddenly ubiquitous diversity and
inclusion offices the tenured professors
of non-binary feminist poetry and other
perverse and pointless fake academic
disciplines as a group these are without
question the least impressive people in
this country and yet they're the only
ones coming out ahead in this deal they
are feasting on our children's debt an
entire generation of Americans in slave
to interest payments so that a small
number of left-wing academics can have
lifetime employment making this country
worse that's the arrangement we've
struck and for the rest of us
socialism that's what we're gonna get
out of it in reaction to it there's got
to be a better way to do things
now some on the Left proposed forgiving
student loans entirely which is to say
sticking American taxpayers with the
bill for all of this if there's one
thing that could make a terrible
situation even worse it's that taxpayers
didn't cause this problem they shouldn't
be punished any more than they already
have been the corrupt higher education
establishment concocted this scam they
should pay to fix it
Harvard's endowment is forty billion
dollars Yale's endowment is thirty
billion so let's start there what's
clear is that we need to move the
crushing financial burden of student
debt off the shoulders of middle-class
families and 22 year-olds and back to
the people who have gotten rich from it
that's the idea that every sensible
person can support and in fact there's a
big political payoff for any politician
wise enough to adopt it the candidate
who promises to make colleges ease the
student loan burden without question be
the next president of the United States